[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver ici
depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble et portes de
l'europe
et voici le programme de cette émission
une émission un peu spécial cette
semaine alors que la pandémie du
coronavirus s'étend dans le monde et en
europe l'italie la france l'allemagne
plus de la moitié des états l'union
recense des cas de contamination
doit-on avoir peur l'europe s'organise t
elle suffisamment pour y faire face les
hôpitaux les urgences du vieux continent
sont ils en ordre de marche
je poserai toutes ces questions à mes
invités en plateau mais avant retour sur
ce nouveau bras de fer entre l'union
européenne et la turquie
la crise migratoire aujourd'hui se
rappelle aux européens par la voix en
l'occurrence du président turc qui a
décidé d'ouvrir grand les frontières
avec l'europe
rappel des faits aurélie la face
quand nous avons ouvert les portes et à
l'heure actuelle environ 18000 personnes
ont franchi ses portes
la turquie a décidé de ne plus retenir
les demandeurs d'asile sur son
territoire le pays avait pourtant conclu
il ya quatre ans un accord avec l'union
européenne
ils s'engageaient à lutter contre le
passage des migrants en échange d'une
aide financière
la turquie cherche aujourd'hui à faire
pression sur l'union alors qu'elle mène
une offensive militaire en syrie et
réclame l'appui des occidentaux
la décision d'ouvrir les frontières a
entraîné un afflux de demandeurs d'asile
aux portes de la grèce et de la bulgarie
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes se présentent à la frontière
la situation est tendue entre les
policiers et les migrants pour aider la
grèce
l'agencé européenne frontex a déployé
des renforts et en signe de solidarité
les dirigeants des institutions
européennes se sont rendus en grèce près
de la frontière turque
la présidente de la commission a annoncé
un soutien financier à la grèce et le
déclenchement du mécanisme de protection
civile
[Musique]
et j'accueille sur ce plateau sylvie
guillaume bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée
française socialistes là pour l'heure
l'urgence c'est quoi c'est de venir en
aide à la grèce de répondre à cette
année à cet appel à l'aide
oui tout à fait il faut d'abord rappeler
plusieurs choses à la grèce s'il dire
aux autorités grecques que quelle que
soit la situation
le refoulement est interdit par les lois
internationales et ont refoulé à des
personnes qui sont en besoin de
protection c'est interdit de la même
manière que refuser de france de
demandes d'asile sites interdits mais
ceci étant dit ça c'est le droit
et puis il ya la pratique évidemment il
faut que les autorités grecques souhaite
aider elles sont c'est un pays qui est
en première ligne comme d'autres
d'ailleurs depuis très intéressante est
celle qui se sent seul qui a été soutenu
financièrement mais le soutien financier
ne suffit pas je crois qu'on assiste
plus qu'à une crise migratoire une crise
de la solidarité et de la responsabilité
commune en europe entre les différents
états membres qui depuis 2015 et 2016 ne
prennent pas leurs responsabilités
collectives et est-ce que vous avez bon
espoir que les vingt-sept sur ces
questions-là en 2020 parlent d'une même
voix
il faut des noës je crois un problème
majeur qui est de savoir comment et par
quels mécanismes avec quelle volonté on
résout le problème de la répartition des
personnes qui demandent à être protégé
si ça le noeud réel et d'amis clairement
qu'ils n'en ont l'air atmo ya des
relents part de responsabilité et
accueillir des demandeurs d'asile il ya
eu des tentatives plusieurs coordonnées
ou pas et qui se sont soldées par des
échecs comme vous le signalez avec des
pays qui disent ok je veux bien mais
d'autres qui disent moi je ne veux pas
et donc personne ne fait réellement le
travail nécessaire
donc il faut des noës ce problème et
puis cessé d'être systématiquement
devant la menace de rétorsions du
président turc parce que globalement la
corde dont vous parlez qui n'est pas
d'un accord d'ailleurs qui est une
déclaration que dans qui est absolument
pas contraignante 4 et signer à trois
personnes cette déclaration de 2016 il
nous l'uma dans la mode voilà nous mais
non c'est ce n'est pas le pacte liant à
ce qu'on appelle communément la rassure
fait donc du coup ça ne peut pas
fonctionner parce que ça nous met sous
la chaleur tage 2
du président erdogan donc il faut
également dans cette crise a réglé la
situation initiale qui est la source et
la guerre ensuit alors justement on le
voit un le président turc est à la
manoeuvre il dit vouloir partager le
fardeau avec l'union européenne la
présidente de la commission si la van
der leyen lui a en quelque sorte répondu
écoutez dos aux sikhs
tout est ce qu'ils cherchent à tester
l'unité de l'europe seront déçus nous
tiendrons la ligne et notre unité
prévaudra l'heure est venue d'agir de
manière concertée de garder la tête
froide et d'agir sur la base de nos
valeurs la turquie n'est pas un ennemi
et les peuples ne sont pas seulement des
moyens pour atteindre un but
means to reach sylvie guillaume faut-il
durcir le ton avec la turquie
il faut être ferme sur les valeurs que
nous défendons
manifestement on a quelques divergences
mais il faut aussi parler parce que
repousser l'adversaire sans lui parler
et il va aller parler ailleurs si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
le président erdogan test effectivement
d'autres types de recours et d'autres
types de dialogues bien fou il ya en
toile de fond le conflit s'est rien
évidemment c'est ce que j'ai indiqué à
l'instant initialement cette crise elle
est aussi liée aux déplacements de
personnes qui fuient une situation de
guerre et de souffrances énormes mais
cette question de la répartition des
personnes est de savoir si on affronte
aussi nos opinions publiques pour dire
tel type ces personnes ont besoin de
notre soutien
ça demande du courage politique sa
demande de l'engagement et il faut que
chacun fasse sa part en la matière au
sein de l'europe il ya notamment les
piques vis gradins pologne hongrie
république tchèque slovaquie qui sont
parmi les plus réfractaires comment
justement on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord à les convaincre que je crois
que nous aurons besoin de passer par des
outils de contraintes alors après il
faut mettre au chlore a posé la main sur
la nature de cette contrainte de cette
responsabilité avec la contrepartie qui
doit aller avec l'absence de réponse
donc avec ces pays riches
et ont estimé qu'on pouvait sens qu'il
pouvait s'en sortir en payant c'est à
dire en monnayant d'une certaine manière
la vie des personnes ce qui est
absolument inadmissible mais c'est parce
que l'europe a fait avec la turquie est
là mais ce n'est pas l'europe
je redis cela l'engagement il est
malheureusement et je le dis de façon
extrêmement ferme l'engagement n'est pas
un engagement qui a été par exemple
validé par le parlement européen
dans cette affaire les élus la
démocratie parlementaire a complètement
été balayé cette décision elle a été
prise à la rage comme on dit en français
dans les banlieues donc il faut vraiment
reprendre cette discussion de façon
sérieuse que c'est tout le monde devant
les responsabilités y compris donc les
pays de ce grade
bien sûr la commission européenne doit
présenter dans quelques semaines son
nouveau pacte de migration dans les
semaines à venir qu'en attendez vous que
doit-on changer alors j'en attends là
aussi que les questions qui se posent de
responsabilité solidaire soit clairement
posé la crainte que j'ai maintenant
c'est qu'une nouvelle fois on n'utilise
pas les outils qui sont à notre
disposition
est ce que par exemple ce pacte va nous
dire le règlement dublin qui est un peu
la clé de voûte de la question de
l'asile dans l'union européenne qui est
oblige la personne l état membre à redon
qui accueille en premier rentrée la
personne qui demande l'asile de traiter
sa demande jusqu'au bout qui est un
mécanisme dans tout le monde convient
qu'il ne fonctionne pas va être
effectivement balayer ou réformer est ce
que par exemple ce pacte ce nouveau
pacte va dire cela et j'ai un peu le
sentiment que ce qu'il va nous être
proposées c'est un peu ce qui est aussi
au coeur de la discussion aujourd'hui
c'est repoussé les questions aux
frontières aux frontières de l'ue 9 et
faire faire le sale boulot entre entre
nous à ceux qui sont les états de
préférer et les états tiers
avec cette idée que les hotspots c'est
quand qu'ils sont des centres de
rétention ou de détention aux frontières
de l'union serait la solution moi je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse considérer que
les personnes qui demandent
soit forcément des gens à mettre en
détention c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire merci sylvie guillaume d'adp
minutes sur notre plateau autre sujet
qui agite le monde et l'europe depuis
plusieurs semaines le coronavirus ou
coville 19
on dénombre plusieurs foyers au sein de
l'union européenne le niveau de risque
est désormais considéré comme élevé le
résumé de la situation avec aurélie
tafas
[Musique]
alors que plus de 3000 personnes dans le
monde sont aujourd'hui décédés à cause
du coronavirus la pandémie s'étend en
europe
le niveau de risque a été relevé de
modéré à fort pour les habitants de
l'union européenne
en d'autres termes le virus continue de
se répandre spread l'italie du nord
constitue le foyer majeur de
contamination en europe avec un nombre
de cas qui augmente fortement de jour en
jour la france est le deuxième pays le
plus touché juste devant l'allemagne
en tout plus de la moitié des états de
l'union recense des cas de contamination
selon le centre européen pour la
prévention et le contrôle des maladies
les états prennent des mesures de
confinement dans les zones à risque et
des recommandations d'hygiène circulent
les autorités conseillent de ne pas se
serrer la main et même en guélat merkel
en allemagne doit s'y plier pour faire
face à l'épidémie
l'union européenne a activé dès la fin
janvier son mécanisme de protection
civile
il permet de renforcer la coopération
entre les états
l'union mobilise également des fonds
pour la recherche sur les coronavirus
[Musique]
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
véronique trier le noir bonjour
eurodéputée française au sein du groupe
renault le groupe centriste européen à
vos côtés alfred cents députée maltais
socialiste bonjour efface avoue benoît
lutgen eurodéputés belges avaient eu le
groupe conservateur
je voudrais d'abord m'adresser à vous
véronique trier le noir vous êtes
médecin de formation doit-on avoir peur
de cette pandémie coronavirus on doit
être vigilant on doit être conscient
qu'une épidémie c est un problème
important
on doit s'organiser on doit anticiper
autant qu'on puisse face à un virus
qu'on connaît peu qu'on connaît mal
puisqu'il est nouveau et émergents donc
on doit prendre collectivement des
mesures qui soient les plus rationnelle
possible qu'ils soient les plus homogène
possible en europe
et là il me semble qu'on a encore une
marge de progression importante
même si la situation est différente d'un
pays d'europe à l'eau alors justement à
malte
je crois pour l'heure il n'y a aucun cas
confirmé de cornavin eux c'est bien cela
jusqu'à maintenant mais on prépare pour
les pires bien sûr suis d'accord avec la
vigilance suis aussi d'accord pour
l'heure avec la vigilance parce que
finalement on sait pas exactement
quelles sont les caractéristiques de ces
virus pas encore si encore beaucoup
d'inconnues
c'est ça alors justement la vigilence
vigilence justement le niveau de risque
en europe est passée de modéré à élevé
ça veut dire concrètement ça veut dire
qu'une progression dans plusieurs états
membres de la pandémie en ailier mais et
qu'on en arrive à des taux qui sont
assez élevés dans certains pays en
france par exemple on est passé on est
au niveau 2 pour l'instant au stade 2 on
passe peut-être peut-être passé au stade
3 aucune progression effectivement du
virus alors la peur n'est pas bonne
conseillère
on n'est pas là pour faire peur on est
là pour essayer de prendre des actions
et des coordonnées au niveau européen
c'est ça plus important aujourd'hui
c'est incompréhensible pour le citoyen
européen qui regarde l'actualité a dans
tous les pays de pouvoir comprendre
quelque part les mesures qui sont prises
état par état qui sont fort différents
d'un état d'un état membre à l'autre
donc un besoin urgent de coordonner
d'avoir des mesures semblables pour que
ce soit compréhensible et aussi dans ce
d'incompréhension que l'ensemble des
citoyens européens qui continuent de
circuler sache exactement qui puisse
savoir exactement comment il va se
comporter et quelles mesures elles
doivent prendre lorsqu'ils se rendent
dans un fouillis et amant de l'oignon
parlé de coordination est ce que la
commission elle en fait assez alors il y
à des mesures qui sont prises en termes
d'information en termes de prévention il
ya une agence européenne qui fait de la
veille sanitaire qui diffusent de
l'information
il ya des actions de coordination au
niveau des états membres il ya
indiscutablement des mesures qui sont
prises il ya du financement de la
recherche
il ya de l'assistance aux pays européens
et aux pays tiers qui ont pu en avoir
besoin
là où je suis complètement d'accord avec
mon collègue c'est que il on est on se
heurte très vite à la relativement
faibles compétences de l'europe en
matière de santé c'est à dire et à
chaque état membre de décider les
recommandations but très vite sur une
limites évidentes qui sont les
prérogatives des états membres en
matière de santé alors il y a du bon à
ce que deux pays comme par exemple malté
la france réagissent différemment on a
une idée on a un pays frontalier on a
des taux de contamination qui ne sont
pas les mêmes mais moi il me semble que
même si on a mis en place des mesures de
coordination de solidarité et d'action
on aurait besoin de plus d'europe de
mieux d'europe
c'est probablement quelque chose qui ne
se fera pas pendant cette crise
sanitaire là mais il me semble qu'une
des leçons que nous devrions en tirer
c'est de monter le niveau des
compétences européennes en matière de
secteurs et sanitaire plus d'europe
alfred cents vous me disiez attention il
nous faut beaucoup beaucoup de vigilance
est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à limiter
la mobilité des citoyens au sein de
l'espace schengen au sein de l'europe
voire fermer les frontières
c'est notre problème ça parce que
justement il ya aussi des conséquences
économiques
par exemple un pic dépend tellement du
tourisme par exemple est ce qu'il va
faire les hôtels les situations les
loisirs que tout ça pour nous par
exemple nous sommes un pays tourisme il
faut aussi penser à ça en italie par
exemple il ya un désastre actuellement
dans l'industrie de l'hôtellerie
justement parce que tout ça ça lui
reconnaît un ami de consommation ne sont
pas à mettre aux côtés n'ont plus l'âge
il faut faire un mélange entre la
vigilance médical complètement strictes
comme ça coordonnées au niveau européen
aussi mais les conséquences économiques
aussi non ça c'est vrai que c'est sur
les répercussions économiques même si
l'union européenne se penche également
de suez au nom du principe de précaution
et pour tenter officiellement d'endiguer
la pandémie le gouvernement de viktor
orban
il se prépare à brec'h des la hongrie
est-ce que c'est clairement un exemple à
suivre
non puisque c'est un exemple qui a un
fonds de casseroles l'idéologique aussi
1,2 de rejeter tout ce qui vient de
l'extérieur des tiers
bien sûr utiliser quelque part ce ce
moment très particulier où justement on
doit coordonner le travail entre états
membres
il ya une forme d'un préparation qui
existe quand même je crois qu'on va
tirer des leçons vous avez parfaitement
raison tirer les leçons de droit de
tirer les leçons de ce qui s'est produit
pour qu'on soit mieux préparée dans la
coordination au niveau européen les
réponses soient davantage harmonisés
d'un état membre à l'autre tenant compte
bien sûr de la réalité de chaque moment
à ce qu'on se dit à chaque fois non
alors alors alors c'est vrai qu'il faut
parfois passer par des crises prenons
l'exemple du terrorisme il a fallu
malheureusement et on peut qu'en pleurer
un de ce qui s'est produit en france en
belgique
il a fallu des drames pour qu'une
coordination beaucoup plus forte
notamment la transmission d'informations
ici concernant le corps d'un virus on
doit avoir cette coordination cette
préparation beaucoup plus forte dans les
flux d'informations dans la façon dont
les choses sont coordonnées ça c'est une
première de son la deuxième si je puis
me permettre
on a conséquemment rendu compte
maintenant c'est flagrant que nous
sommes très dépendants notamment en
matière de médicaments à l'égard de
l'asie de la chine en particulier et on
se retrouve en pénurie on savait déjà il
ya dix fois plus de pénurie depuis dix
ans auparavant de médicaments sur le
continent européen
stratégiquement l'europe doit pouvoir
garantir l'approvisionnement la
production sur son territoire de
médicaments pour faire face aux besoins
de sa population
ce n'est pas normal d'être dépendant de
la chine à ce point on l'entend et en
cas d'accélération de la pandémie et la
multiplication du nom
mot de personnes infectées nos hôpitaux
en europe et d'un sont ils prêts comment
les urgences se prépare-t-elle je vous
propose de prendre la direction des
pays-bas où on a tout fait depuis des
années pour désengorger les urgences et
éviter ainsi les salles d'attentes bondé
c'est un reportage de jérémy huntsman
[Musique]
utrecht quatrième ville des pays-bas
dans ce grand hôpital à l'accueil des
urgences des banquettes vides et des
médecins urgentistes qui prennent le
temps de discuter
c'est une journée normale à l'accueil
alors commencé à vendredi
l'une de nos journées les plus chargées
à la proche du week end
ici personne ne vient directement car
aux pays-bas en cas d'urgence
quelle que soit sa gravité tout le monde
passe d'abord par un numéro unique le
dans ce centre d'appels arnhem près
d'utrecht policiers pompiers et
infirmiers travaillent côte à côte
chaque jour 300 appels concernent d'un
problème médical
c'est alors au lave qui décrochent par
goom la première chose qu'on demande aux
patients c'est son adresse et des cons à
l'information on en voit déjà une
ambulance prévu pour arriver en un quart
d'heure pendant qu'elle est en route je
pose des questions aux patients show son
état de santé
je rentre ses données dans le système
selon plusieurs critères et en fonction
de la gravité
je dessine si l'ambulance continue ou si
elle doit revenir à quelques kilomètres
dans ce service d'ambulance ces deux
infirmiers terminent leurs préparatifs
une fois chez le patient ils lui
donneront les premiers soins si
nécessaire mais ne l'emmèneront pas
forcément aux urgences un son spatial
faille parfois nous pouvons faire en
sorte de rassurer le patient avec un
soin adapté et parfois nous pouvons
simplement lui apporter des explications
sur ce qu'il a pour qu'ils se sentent
mieux
le patient peut alors resté chez lui ou
être réorientés vers son médecin
généraliste et pour sylvie infirmière
depuis onze ans ce modèle d'organisation
a fait ses preuves l'an dernier nous
avons vu environ cent mille patients et
nous avons eu seulement huit erreurs de
diagnostic aux urgences le patient est
pris en charge en 15 minutes est
redirigé vers le service adapté
résultat aucune saturation
mais il ya une autre raison à ceux
désengorgement une franchise de 387
euros par an pour la première visite à
l'hôpital
même si l'urgence est avérée nous voyons
80 à 100 patients par jour aux urgences
sans le système de filtrage nous
verrions 300 ou 400 patients par jour et
c'est beaucoup plus que ce que nous
pouvons supporter la fréquentation des
urgences a même baissé de moitié au
début des années 2000 et la raison se
trouve derrière ces murs de briques
nous sommes à dry bergen à 1h d'utrecht
dans l'une des 130 coopératives de
médecins généralistes du pays une offre
de soins de proximité complète
ça c'est la pharmacie
quand on fait une ordonnance aux
patients elle arrive directement ici et
le patient peut récupérer ces
médicaments centres d'appels chambre
avec brancards d'urgence ici tout est
regroupé médecin généraliste depuis 25
ans
karine effectué des consultations
entièrement remboursé de 8 heures à 19
heures le soir et les week-ends elle est
quatre autres médecins se relaient pour
assurer des permanences des patients
quoi qu'il arrive
les patients viennent d'abord me voir -
avec leurs symptômes leurs questions
leurs maladies même dans les cas
d'urgence
s'ils ont du mal à respirer par exemple
ils viennent d'abord me voir en tant que
médecin généraliste
nous sommes les gardiens du système de
santé nous protégeons en quelque sorte
les portes des urgences car nous
décidons si un patient doit oui ou non
entrer à l'hôpital at a time it
un système efficace qui a un certain
prix
depuis 2006 et le désengagement de
l'état la santé aux pays-bas repose sur
un modèle entièrement libéral chaque
citoyen doit payer une assurance maladie
de base d'environ 120 euros par mois
sans compter la complémentaire pour les
néerlandais la qualité des soins reçus
justifie ce coût élevé rail cup au cas
où dort ou cardiaques et j'ai déjà été
hospitalisés dans d'autres pays je n'ai
jamais été prise en charge aussi
rapidement qu ici le système est
vraiment fantastique
je ne serais même pas devant vous
aujourd'hui si ce système n'existe de ce
mineur a une comme je suis étudiante
c'est très satisfaisant parce que je les
aide supplémentaire
par exemple je suis remboursé 200 euros
sur ma franchise annuelle si je vais à
l'hôpital avec moi je ne suis jamais
malade ça me va parfaitement
chaque année je reçois un bonus et je
paie moins cher chez cette association
de défense des patients
le constat est similaire si le système
peut encore s'améliorer
il ne laisse personne de côté for men
c'est bien sûr la santé coûte cher ici
jours mais il existe des aides pour les
gens qui ont de faibles revenus football
ces personnes l'état prend en charge une
grande partie des frais
en rapportant au nombre d'habitants les
néerlandais vont 3 x man aux urgences
que les français et bénéficie de
meilleurs soins avec le deuxième système
de santé le plus performant d'europe
[Musique]
ironique trier le noir un commentaire
sur ce fonctionnement aux pays bas une
source d'inspiration pour les hôpitaux
en france
alors je n'ai pas envie de faire de
commentaire ni de comparaison bilatérale
d'un pays à l'autre ce qui crève les
yeux en gardant ce commentaire ce sont
les disparités qui existent entre les
pays d'europe en terme d'organisation
des soins de premier recours
en termes de valorisation des profession
infirmière en termes de remboursement
des frais de santé
globalement les pays du nord ont
beaucoup d' avance en termes de
prévention
ce que je retiens de tout cela c'est que
cette extrême disparité contribue
probablement à cette forme de cacophonie
que vous dénonciez tout à l'heure
concernant l'organisation européenne de
la prise en charge d'une crise sanitaire
et que nous pourrions travailler tous
collectivement non pas à les gommer
complètement parce que nous avons toutes
les spécificités mais à prendre chez
chacun ce qu'il y a de meilleur alfred
cents les professionnels de santé
partout en europe ça va être les
premiers sur le front un pour faire face
à la pandémie de coronavirus est-ce que
vous pensez que ils sont prêts notamment
à malte vaut les hôpitaux comment
comment ça fonctionne chez vous nous
avons insisté me préparer pour l'urgence
de la pandémie quand elle arrive ça a
été arrangé 7 en place effectivement le
problème n'est ce pas c'est de voir
casbah qui se va se passer il faut qu'il
ya deux premiers cas parce que un
problème de panique sociale il faut
faire attention à cela
justement comme pour un pays de tourisme
comme ils sont très près de l'italie
la panique n'est pas évident surtout
dans ces petites communautés comme la
nôtre les hôpitaux sont équipés pour ça
mais il faut voir ce qui va se passer
quand ça va se passer
c'est justement le problème et oui c'est
bien d'avoir une coordination au niveau
européen
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
marché unique dans le secteur de la
santé pour l'instant
alors pour arriver jusque là il faut
faire pas mal de choses suis pas
convaincu tout le monde
c'est un marché en europe
on peut rêver mais ça ne servirait pas
tout de suite dans les entreprises n'ont
pas entendu l'europe travaille également
ensemble sur le territoire sur le
territoire européen par delà les
frontières mais par contre d'une
coordination plus importante
et comme je l'indiquais tout à l'heure
qu'il y aussi une production stratégique
pour moi le les soins de santé
l'alimentation notamment l'énergie si je
pensais 3 trois éléments la prévention
c'est stratégique pour l'europe pour que
les citoyens se disent aussi ok j'ai des
réponses très concrètes dernier mot les
soins de santé
c'est vraiment d'enjeu démocratique
aussi de proximité plus vous êtes
éloigné d'un hôpital plus vous êtes
éloigné des soins de santé plus vous
êtes santé abandonné les territoires
oubliés de la france qu'on connaît bien
c'est un critère quelque part de
détermination aussi de la fois qu'on a
on la démocratie en europe en
particulier une note d'optimisme il ya
des sujets de santé qui vont arriver au
niveau de l'union européenne et du
parlement européen celui des pénuries de
médicaments
clairement nous avons réalisé
et l'état de dépendance dans lequel nous
sommes vis-à-vis des grandes puissances
comme la chine et l'inde qui fabriquent
toutes les substances actives
il y à une prise de conscience nous
avions lutté l'harmonisation de
l'évaluation des médicaments
c'est un rapport qui s'appelle html
technology assessment où nous allons
travailler ensemble sur une meilleure
manière d'harmoniser nos médicaments
peut-être même d'aller jusqu'à sinon une
harmonisation du moins en gommage les
différences de prix qui sont
actuellement fixés par les industriels
de santé au prorata de la soutenabilité
des états
cette forme de soufre and it et
européenne en matière de santé
probablement pas un marché unique mais
un progrès dans le domaine louis je le
vois et là encore les crises sanitaires
permettent des prises de conscience est
probablement une accélération de ses
peintures alors nettement dépendent en
effet de la chine ou autres plus ou
vairelles de production médicaments je
voudrais qu'on vienne à l'exemple des
pays-bas alfred cents on voit une
franchise de 387 euros par an pour
accéder aux urgences à l'hôpital
est ce que ça vous semble normal ça me
semble un peu bizarre franchement mais
on comprend des réseaux économiques et
financières des rires chez nous tous les
hôpitaux sont libres sont libres d'accès
gratuit totalement gratuit alors je suis
en train de faire quelque chose comme ça
dans des systèmes ça causerait des
problèmes politiques incroyable
finalement dans tous ses sites tous les
systèmes médicaux j'imagine il faut
toujours tenir en tête ce qui si vous
voulez la consommateurs est plus
important le médecin précieux
ils coopèrent pas alors on n'avance pas
on voit bien quand même qui est d'un
pays à l'autre les offres de santé les
offres de soins sont très différentes et
si je serais pas un peu plus uniformisée
notamment parce qu' on voit fleurir le
tourisme en europe
c'est une réalité bien sûr que je ne
l'étais en europe dans les deux sens
d'ailleurs à en des habitants des pays
de l'est qui viennent se faire soigner
chez nous à verser mans pour des raisons
parfois tarif est tout simplement
cette harmonisation la permettra aussi
d'éviter cela il ya aussi une pénurie de
médecins très importante
plus tôt dans nos pays france belgique
que notamment et on va chercher nos
médecins en roumanie ou ailleurs ou des
français ou des belges qui vont se
former là bas parce qu'elle numerus
clausus on marche sur la tête
donc on doit redonner confiance
notamment aux jeunes aux étudiants en
médecine aux infirmiers ou infirmières
en leur donnant la possibilité d'avoir
une profession chez nous et de pouvoir
la développer
durant les années qui viennent ça n'a
aucun sens d'année soit en europe soit
ailleurs chercher des professions qui
pourrait très bien se développer chez
nous donc on a quelque part bridel
système et c'est un accès d'un intérêt
bien sûr collectif mais suscitait donner
la possibilité à chacun d'avoir son
propre parcours professionnel et
médicales tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qui vient d'être dit complètement en
phase d'après entre le moment où on le
dit et le moment où on le met en
application
ça prendra du temps mais il ya quand
même des gérants des directives
européennes sur les soins
transfrontaliers
à mon avis c'est là dessus sur ces
textes législatifs existants qu'ils
feront probablement s'appuyer pour aller
vers plus d'europe et mieux de repenser
ans que vous êtes tous les trois
d'accord autour de 7
merci à tous les trois ce sont les mots
de la fin vous pouvez voir et revoir
cette émission il plaît sur le site
internet de public sénat mais aussi sur
l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes
[Musique]